why hello there welcome two reasons to
see i'm ryan right gonna provide you
with movie news in three minutes or less
what's originally gonna be 90 seconds
but i love the sound of my own voice too
much first big story jared leto or Leto
or I don't care has showed a picture to
us of himself as the Joker he's tatted
up bad chief and jeez he looks like the
Joker but like a 1980s punk rock version
several films have got an official
release dates from Universal Pictures
the mummy reboot is set for March twenty
four twenty seventeen I have been
wondering where the mummy franchise has
been Pacific Rim to march seven 2017
let's see if people still remember what
Pacific Rim is by the time that comes
out Furious 8 april twenty four twenty
seventeen we all saw that coming coming
Johnny Depp's new movie black mass is
getting a lot of attention right now
because it looks like he's not playing
Jack Sparrow again he's actually doing a
real character as James Whitey Bulger
lil Jerry thanks buddy a remake of The
Invisible Man is in the works with the
Invisible Man set to be a villain let me
tell you if I was the Invisible Man I
would sneak in on my girlfriend when
she's needed because she doesn't let me
see her naked star trek 3 may have a new
title star trek beyond which is linked
to Batman Beyond and it takes place at
the place beyond the pines blasting
parts are not true Henry Cavill work
ville has officially said that no Batman
vs Superman is not a man of steel sequel
it's about introducing Batman and the
Justice League that's what we already
thought when we thought it was a man of
steel sequel Adam McKay's the big short
is going into production with a huge
[ __ ] cast sexy hunk who's now in his
fifties Brad Pitt a man who we once
thought would be in big-time comedian
but his careers kind of gone south Steve
Carell and actor it takes himself way
too seriously
sometimes Christian Bale and the man was
hung like a horse god Ryan Gosling
universal has announced that there is
now going to be a transformer Cinematic
Universe I don't give a [ __ ] anyway guys
that's the movie news of the week that I
thought was interesting if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter and you
can also catch my videos on Latino
Review com a website dedicated to the
Latino community but even white people
get access to it when I want the NOI
Latino news on movies i go to latino
reveal man but they don't just do Latino
meals they do gringo news they do black
news higher on